j'ai réussi durant les trois jours de
consultation va faire si doses de vaccin
toutes les autres personnes ont refusé
le vaccin
voilà personne n'en veut j'ai donc ici
dans la main sans doute un des outils
thérapeutiques les plus efficaces contre
les virus
ce vaccin est à présent périmés je suis
obligé de le jeter en pleine pandémie je
vais donc jeté des vaccins à la poubelle
parce que plus personne n'en veut voilà
alors cette vidéo elle a été énormément
vu et patrick votre médecin généraliste
merci d'être là merci merci c'est vrai
que vous avez fait un buzz incroyable
avec cette vidéo
pourquoi vous êtes fignon pour dénoncer
cette situation d dit tiens voilà je
vais je vais montrer voilà ce que ça va
ça va avoir plus d'ampleur de la nation
je crois qu'il faut resituer un peu là
le contexte chimie de c1 mulhouse
rappelez vous il ya un an mulhouse était
ravagé par huit déjà pris un peu parole
à ce moment là et puis s'est retrouvée
un an après médecin mulhouse avec
l'accession qui tombe en panne
c'est un cri de colère c'est un cri de
désespoir il faut que quelque chose
change parce que visiblement tous les
français tous les gens n'ont pas compris
l'impact et le ski important dans cette
vaccination en fait on a un choix facile
le coït où le vaccin
si on veut sortir de ça c'est le vaccin
après il faut que ça soit bien compris
c'est vrai que le message autour du
vaccin astra a été pour le moins
brouillée rappelez vous il d'abord
interdite pour les plus de 65 ans puis
autorisé pour les 70 ans puis après
autorisé jusqu'à 75 ans et plus si après
interdit et après interdit pour les
moins de 65 ans et après à fabrique
au bout d'un moment le message est
extrêmement est brouillée chez les gens
et je crois qu'il faut clarifier les
choses en disant que c'est un outil
thérapeutique majeur il faut qu'on s'en
sert intelligemment les gens le
demandent peut-être pas la tranche d'âge
manoqué concernés par la vaccination
mais j'ai tous les jours des coups de
fil de gens plus jeunes des enseignants
des travailleurs des gens qui discutent
et je veux être vacciné je suis prêt à
prendre le risque pour le sable sera
sachant que le risque est minuscule
c'est un giro minuscule mode brisons là
il ya un travail de communication à
faire parce qu'il ya eu en premier truc
sur la stasi les caves où ils ont changé
de nom ya plusieurs choses changent en
on sait ce que c'est
effectivement astrazeneca où il ya eu
des réticences parce que à un moment on
s'est posé des questions sur est ce que
le vaccin était sûre est ce que le
vaccin n'était pas sûr aujourd'hui et je
parle sous votre contrôle docteur c'est
un vaccin qui est sûr et qu'il faut
utiliser
et puis l astre et yverdon et la
stratégie du gouvernement c'est de
vacciner dans un premier temps les
personnes les plus âgées les plus âgés
les personnages ils travaillent ils
et c'est ce qui est en train d'être fait
en ce moment et puis à la question
faut-il ouvrir la vaccination
la vaccination elle va s'ouvrir alors
fur et à mesure aux plus jeunes et à
l'été on aura tous accès à la
vaccination donc c'est une question de
temps alors justement parce que c'est la
grosse question du jour à vous poser
toute la question aussi y en a plein à
tous les gens qui me regardent les 15-34
ans voilà qui sont très nombreux à nous
regarder nous dise quand est ce qu'on va
être vaccinés nous on en a marre on a
envie d'aller en soirée oui fait bien
voyager
oui je les gardais brégeon excusez moi
c'est surréaliste mais n'avait pas de
vaccin moulins mâcon à des vaccins on
n'a personne pour valeur vacciner c'est
vrai mais c'est plus pour les français
totalement à quoi pensent-ils wallers
harcouët pourquoi vous n'ouvrez pas par
exemple en seine saint denis un
département jeunes qui en demandent à
quoi tous les jeunes de
seine-saint-denis ne peuvent pas se
faire vacciner d'ici je le pense que
d'ici quelques jours ou quelques
semaines en tout cas au fur et à mesure
qu'on avance ça va s'ouvrir la
vaccination elle va s'ouvrir vous
l'avais dit il ya quelque part une bonne
nouvelle en tout cas si on veut regarder
le verre à moitié plein c'est qu'il ya
deux semaines j'étais sur ce plateau et
on se plaignait collectivement du fait
qu'il n'y avait pas suffisamment de
doses et que on attendait que les
vaccins arrivent en france aujourd'hui
les doses elles arrivent petit à petit
et donc la vaccination elle va s'ouvrir
au fur et à mesure que le calendrier
avance yahoo il faut pas penser que le
gouvernement prend plaisir à laisser des
doses dans des réfrigérateurs
patrick quand on voit mais le truc c'est
pas sa mode c'est quand on voit toutes
les doses qui sont jolies mais voilà on
peut pas faire un cadeau ou le soir
quand il a 200 doses pas tous les
volontaires asile et qu'aime justement
ça a été précisé hier par le ministre de
la santé olivier ferrand qui disait que
dans chaque centre
la directive qui est donné c'est à la
fin de la journée d'une part utiliser
les carnets de rappel où il rappelle les
personnes qui sont dans la cible de la
vaccination
et si jamais elles ne viennent pas ils
élargissent j'ai trouvé patrick la
différence c'est que machines médecins
généralistes de vacciner dans mon
cabinet l'instant je n'ai accès que ça
sera peut-être le johnson quand elles
seraient livrées mais pour l'instant on
ne classe crâ hop hop hop et pouvaient
pape est peut-être dès janvier oui c'est
une logistique de fou vient cette
consultation il doit plaider gars ouais
c'est compliqué d'affaires paru la
semaine dernière ben on a jusqu'à
présent j'ai réussi à vacciner pas loin
de 150 personnes durant le donc c'est
beaucoup quoi tout ça derrière des
problèmes aux héros problème ton nom du
psychiatre combattu faire des choses non
mot merci à deux pas de forme grave non
bien sûr
et la semaine dernière j'ai donc ouvert
comme tous les lundis un flacon de
d'astra et puis donc le mardi lundi j'ai
pu faire trois vaccins marni 3 et puis
et g mercredi un nom qui me restait
quatre doses à midi donc le vaccin est
périmée à midi parce que je dois ouvrir
lundi à midi ça j'ai pas le temps passer
des dizaines de coups de feu dans dix
ans à venir le vaccin était rien focus
3e et qu'il faut quand même dire
qu'aujourd'hui il est autorisé pour les
plus de 5 oui justement de toute façon
pas appeler des personnes j'ai sauté
haut ce que c'est intenable
alors moi j'avoue que j'ai eu accès la
semaine dernière des gens de 53 ans de
54 ans ricky et voilà avec la banda
parce que entre 53 et 54 ans ne me dit
pas quelle réalité scientifique c c'est
une logique c'est comme les trucs péri
mais voilà rien pour toi ton rouge après
le 18 la question tu vas pas attraper la
pagaille
la question qui se pose est ce qu'on
préfère que le type de 50 fois en
attrape le comique plutôt que je le hac
six mois avec un vaccin efficace
doc et moi en tant que médecin choix est
vite fait je le vaccine je trouve les
règles non mais en plus chez monsieur il
dit j'ai 53 ans je me faire vacciner
avec la sq raser les gars qui sont
versées mais non urgentes ont pris mais
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
pourquoi les doses sont jetés parce que
les gens ont peur il ya des milliers de
milles des millions de gens qui ont peur
et ils n'ont plus confiance en ses
vaccins de megan a décidé de recycler
les vaccins c'est qu'on l'hiérarchie un
peu les gens les personnes malades ils
ne veulent pas d'astrazeneca
c'est pas grave on va faire les plus
jeunes puis on verra bien alors qu'on
attend mais là ce n'est qu'à ces plus de
55 ans mêlant veut faire vacciner les
jeunes avec astrazeneca qu'est-ce que
vous
le tout mais c'est quoi qu'est-ce que
les doses qui sont je laisse mes parts
on parle on parle de deux trucs on dit
est-ce qu'il faut que si vacciner tout
le monde non parce que les gens n'ont
plus confiance en des vaccins eu la même
chose avec la folie des bandes on veut
plus en france va envoyer en à cette
idée j'ai donné un exemple tu donnes un
exemple précis à mes patients je dis
imaginons qu'on vaccine tout le
département du haut-rhin sept cent mille
personnes tout le département avec de
l'astra sur sept cent mille personnes on
risque d'avoir un décès et au lieu
d'avoir trois cas de thrombose pour tout
le département mais le département après
lequel il n'y a plus personne qui fait
le pont donc c'est le choix le
département c'est quoi la réalité du
commis dans l'ue à sion ils sont chauds
pour se faire vacciner astrazeneca ou
pas du tout mais non ils sont ils sont
et ce qu'ils lisent les hippos dans le
dos leur imaginaire c'est le vaccin
donne des canons de trois doigts
ce n'est pas vrai c'est un pur 700 mille
cas de la bce
oui mais seulement rappeler qu'il faut
rappeler mais les autres vaccins aussi
d'effets secondaires pendant ce temps là
exactement imaginer le problème c'est
qu'on va vacciner 40 millions de
personnes manquant même de gérer ça près
par défi moi je demande ayew ça ne fait
pas rêver quand tu vois l'angleterre ça
ne fait pas rêver quand tu vois israël
ces pratiques sont fermés les magasins
sont fermés donnée essentielle moi j'ai
envie d'aller au cinéma j'ai envie
d'habiter adjamé de voyager en terrasse
mais oui mais moi ça ne fait pas rêver
quand je vois toutes les polémiques tous
les effets secondaires les gens qui sont
morts les gens qui tirent et on te dit
que pour la sécurité routière il faut
mettre des gens n'ont pas conscience il
a passé même qu'ici on va forcer les
gens à se faire vacciner
l'aqlpa mais ça que tu pour voyager par
n'imposez pas là dessus bien sûr ton et
la reine ont souvent un truc aussi alors
et je n'aime pas de son discours dits
âgés et bien peu importe c'est ce qui va
se passer y en a forcément actionnaires
à mon avis ce sera lille ce sera comme
ça alors oui pardon dans la partie
d'émission
j'ai mis un jingle chez pour toi merci
tu comparer à l'angleterre
effectivement ça nous fait tous rêver
qu'on voit à l'angleterre énormément de
personnes vaccinées les bars en tout cas
les peuples en terrasse qu'on ait ouvert
rendra aussi en france il ya c'est une
autre contrainte lala contraintes
auxquelles on a eu à faire face
c'est l'approvisionnement des doses
c'est ça qui fait qu'on en ait pas au
niveau de l'angleterre aujourd'hui
astrazeneca
il se déploie pour les plus de 55 ans et
je pense que c'est peut-être un des
messages principaux qu'on doit passer ce
soir c'est c'est un vaccin qui est sur
la balance bénéfice risque
elle est largement dans le sens de la
vaccination et ensuite la le le nombre
de doses qui arrivent et le fait qu'on
en ait beaucoup ça vient notamment de
pfizer et moderne actions des vaccins
dans lesquelles les gens ont confiance
et donc on aura tous accès à la
vaccination est une question qui est
posée
les vaccins comment ça se passe il vous
livre est donc c'est qui qui alors donc
une s'inscrit on s'inscrit à la
pharmacie de proximité qui est livrée et
donc on a un mail tout le même et donc
c'est à pharmacie qui payent des vaccins
c'est qu'on annonce est payé par l'état
tout est pas compter à gratter tout là
tout c'est ça ouais mais après donc la
tour des comptes laisser les milliers
vous jetez tout les oui mais alors là
sera est moins cher il vaut à peu près 1
euro merci je t'ai je suis désolé
j'étais pour 4 euros de vaccins dans la
poubelle l'autre jour que vous avez
avoué donc ça fait 3000
oui monsieur non ce qu'était un très
important c'est que un médecin comme
vous cher docteur que je respecte
évidemment c'est vous qui allez chercher
le flacon vous devez prévenir vos
patients vous devez vous organisé à
savoir qui vous aller vacciner très
choquant je termine je trouve ça très
choquant de devoir jeter du vaccin mais
on en a besoin
moi je crois que c'est à vous à vous
organisez vous connaissez vos pages
organisé non mais là donc ça veut dire
que pour toi et je le dis dans est
respectée s'il vous plaît souple et les
médecins il ancre à l'ail de fou et il
est mais qu'en plus ils sont vraiment
ils sont tous personnes âgées du vaccin
on les connaît sa valeur médicale
c'est-à-dire qu'elle faisait quoi avant
elle a du travail à ce prix là car je
peux vous dire que big mac est donné à
l'événement
tu travailles pas tu sais non non mais
l'image qui est donnée à l'étranger les
désastreuses non à des dizaines de deux
buteurs étrangers qui nous on a plein de
mecs
qu'est ce que c'est que ces images en
france parce que ils ont bien compris
qu'ils ont lu mes nouveaux de
gouvernement est complètement dingue
parce qu'ils ont vu les salles des
vaccinodromes et les gens que ça en 170
magasins sans rien non non j'en connais
deux valises pas de patients vaccinés à
l'époque on vraiment que je mangeais
dans la tête
guillot je comprends et tu as le droit
si tu n'as pas les lits personne ne va
dire sur gilts vacciner évidemment il
sait pas la police de la pensée unique
et tu as tout à fait le droit de pas te
rendre toi à ton cabinet en revanche ce
n'est pas parce que toi tu n'as pas
envie qu'il faut interdire à ceux qui en
ont envie l'axé et c'est une analyse à
l'erreur à mon sens ou en tout cas le
fait que ça n'aille pas je lis puisque
encore une fois là jean castex
aujourd'hui a dit on va on maintient
calendrier là on va ouvrir à ceux qui
ont 50 ans avec des comorbidités n'en
descend pas encore en dessous or il ya
des gens qui aujourd'hui aimerait
pouvoir aller voir ce monsieur il allait
dose et
vous voyez alors que ces gens-là frappe
à la porte de cabinet pour dire moi
j'aimerais bien thaksin et moi je suis
d'accord je signe ou et j'ai peu importe
je je fais aussi d'une décharge s'il ya
un souci
donc voilà c'est pas si c'est ça ne la
laverai khaled pour ceux qui souhaitent
qui a été donné par olivier ferrand
était qu'on est con je dois jeter aucune
dose et jean castex à l'adie aujourd'hui
jean castex est dit aujourd'hui que
effectivement ça allait s'ouvrir petit à
petit qui regardez bien le nombre de
rendez vous qui restez libre et que si
effectivement il y avait autant de
rendez vous que ce qu'on peut entendre
par ci et par là notamment dans les
médias on ouvrirait encore davantage
donc de toutes façons
non on utilise toutes les doses qu'on a
bondi à près de 15 millions d'ha
cohérent lassus premier à d'ores et on
va continuer à vacciner cité de la
vernière de castaldi pour moi parce que
c'est pas le vaccin ror est juste
[Applaudissements]
souple et bernard montiel géraldine ben
non mais ça va je commence à fatiguer
oui tout est dépassé depuis longtemps
mais alors c'est le présent dans la
tranche j'ai 64 ans moi ma pharmacie en
bas il m'a appelé vous êtes dans la
tranchée à dresser wayne c'est nettement
plus que dans la prochaine à la tronche
et à 12 non mais et vous est-ce que vous
êtes vacciné banon mais bon quand même
mais attendez malgré les vacciner le
retard la version elizabeth je suis
inquiet pour me faire vacciner oui vous
avez envie de vous faire vacciner ou pas
ben oui moment sera venu se faire
soigner à l'asra zeneca ah oui ouais
d'accord avec monsieur personnes 4
millions qui sont dans la cible qui ont
droit de se faire vacciner et le n'y
vont pas bah ouais mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fout mal au dos d'âne sur arte
d'économie nous regarde que vous avez
des parents qu'on a plus de 55 ans
falloir bien d'aller dans mes pense à
toi qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ] de
l'audience de rtl c'est cuit la vacciner
il savait gagner isabelle je t'aime
beaucoup ma chérie mais cette oreille et
je pense à toi tu es ma chérie gilles
verdez aussi la 202 ans qu'est ce qui
fait leur preuve et sans déconner c'est
pourquoi moi je moi je ne demande rien à
personne moi on met nos frères en plus
de 55 j'ai 56 ans n'y va pas j'ai peur
de astrazeneca
je ne veux pas le astrazeneca vacciner
non mais j'en rêve et j'espère être
vaccinés très bientôt mais c'est vrai
qu'il est heureusement pour moi d'après
navale moi je suis très inquiet pour
isabelle je te prends rendez vous demain
chez vous
[Applaudissements]